o lado dos pobres tô
renan o que falam de mim há nenhum outro
beijo não o lado pessoal de quem fala é
o lugar que seja muito bem vindo já fez
um vídeo e os estragos e que não sei que
o futuro
vamos lá ver aqui que eu posso gravar um
novo disco faz um tutorial e mostrados
aqui um tutorial de como esmagar uma
lata na testa
a proteste faz mais uma lata na testa eu
acho que o curta colatto sentir a
assembléia de deus o proteja a cabeça
com um toque só sei que foi lançada hoje
nós vamos fazer uma coisa que seja adora
animação com estragos chamas na foram
contra fight night at freddy's na minha
opinião esta animação representa muito
bem o que vai ser o final furou que um
jogo é que vai ser um misto de ler
peguei com um ataque de coisas que já vi
por aí vem segundo desta animação é por
isso que eu só saí mas não quis ir mais
pra ver com você e é isso que vai
acontecer agora em 32 como cair aqui
está meu deus não dói não dói e no final
fui eu
vamos expulsar a coroa do bambu boy
o fred já está há 15 dias as coisas né
agora vai responder na o seu fred enfim
da mãe
não acho que não é esse apoio é muito é
muito confusa no cérebro
o casal vai responder está explodindo
mundo é meu a não dar por vencido não é
meu é isso
o caio fred vai usar o mototáxi
microfone choque o vento é que esta
animação a partida que eu já não vi mais
porque pronto é ok o godói vai usar
agora o twitter da coroa vai agora
responder o contato da mega super
difícil
tá ok o blog vai o blog vai ficar com os
parques bull ainda não morreu e não é
desta
basicamente esta vai ser em sentido
final furou a doença cárie entender que
seu vôo complexas
acho que vai ficar o governo inscreve o
west brom tal meu
ninguém consegue ser um bundão fred
ninguém
a bombom e agora os gorros brinde trata
agora vai ser uma batalha uma batalha
ficar um só povo e este é meu deus
morreu lhe dão choque falar pra ele vai
usar um batom cachorro
acho que é isso anão bora não estava
totta o boi acabou de provar as baterias
já pra ele né
se não sair a não é assim
ok a atriz do filme foram roubadas e
agora essa triste
o x7 bola domingos alves um garoto só
uma parte da história do rock
ayew morreu
o op sábado pelo ganharam já foram
de carne um álbum boy já vão conquistar
o castelo à influência da casa
o op é humano e tenho microfone e chamou
fred é um rosa tem um moinho não
conseguiu resistir
eu não consegue assistir eu eu não eu
conheço o lula não não resistiu à
tentação foi isso não é o deus a não
sair não sai produzir em inglês
viram só deu um tapa possuído virou a
cabeça para achar o hge do exorcista
fred tem que ter calma com que fred é
também gastar com o espírito da conorte
já e agora vai tomar conta do mundo um
mês só deu não é só ter o fred está a
contento agora vira vai se alinha outro
lado de antonio acabou então é isso
a animação foi de apenas 4 minutos eu
sair é pequena mas acho que valeu a pena
a animação tá bom é assim eu acho que
sempre fica bem o que vai ser no final o
uol é só pra te ver um estado já sabem
quanto você vai que favorito e agora vou
ter que tratar desta frida porque eu sou
uma vez tanto o público enfim quem vai
até a próxima